castaña es temprano pero matías está
listo para iniciar el recorrido
en plena semana santa este guía
turístico argentino radicado hace 11
años y medio en israel lidera un paseo
por el monte de los olivos con un grupo
de 35 españoles nos estamos que es lo
que es una reapertura de la frontera se
le ha permitido volver a disfrutar de su
profesión después de dos años marcados
por la pandemia
[Aplausos]
no fue fácil sinceramente
hubo que rebuscárselas con lo que había
veníamos realmente de épocas muy buenas
de turismo en las cuales se pensaba que
iba a seguir creciendo exponencialmente
lamentablemente un día para otro esto se
cortó algo que nunca esperábamos antes
del freno abrupto por el hobbit 19
israel había recibido un récord de 455
millones de turistas en 2019 55 por
ciento de ellos cristianos por eso la
semana santa tiene un atractivo
particular
también para los comerciantes golpeados
por la ausencia de visitantes graves a
ese nivel aunque el regreso es paulatino
esa es una ventaja para este grupo de
peregrinos hoy que después de postergar
varias veces su viaje recorre con calma
espacios que les conectan con su fe y
que supone estar dónde
estuvo cristo donde supone todo podemos
rezar podemos extraer los sitios con
tranquilidad pero efectivamente después
de aprenderme el amén es esperanzador
para un cristiano ver los lugares santos
y vivir los lugares santos es algo
importantísimo bajo un intenso sol
primaveral matías no pierde la sonrisa y
avanza a pie firme de la misma manera
que desea que ocurra con su sector
seguimos con la esperanza de que esto
sea solamente un comienzo de que de aquí
sigamos creciendo y que para el año que
viene no seamos solamente algunos guías
sino que todos los días podemos estar
encontrándonos en estos lugares y
todavía lejos del promedio de 100 mil
visitantes que recibir en semana santa
que no salen disfrutan del repudio de
los del turismo religioso
que se enfría la comida